good morning everybody welcome to this
meeting of the joint overview and
scrutiny committee
well first remind you of some domestic
arrangements toilets are situated
outside the meeting room opposite the
stairs you start there cold water is
also available in the breakout area
outside the meeting room if the fire
alarm should sound please leave the
meeting room by following the fire exit
signs and meet on the Ipswich Town
Football Club training pitch do not
re-enter the building until you're told
it's safe to do so please switch off all
mobile phones we'll turn them to silent
thank you I'd like to remind everybody
present that this meeting will be
broadcast live on the internet and will
be capable of repeated viewing the whole
of the meeting will be filmed except
where there are confidential or exempt
items if you make a representation to
the meeting you will have been deemed by
the council to have consented to being
filmed and to the possible use of those
images and sound recordings or
webcasting and/or for training purposes
the council members of the public and
the press may record film photograph
will broadcast this meeting when the
public and the press are not lawfully
excluded finally can members and
officers and witnesses please ensure
that you press the microphone for
speaking and turn off when you've
finished now I'll introduce as there's
so many of us here I'll introduce who
everybody is I'm Keith while I'm
chairing the meeting I have support here
from democratic services and with people
up there who are operating the technical
staff here we have members of the
committee we also have other members of
council including members of the the SIL
committee that's looking into changing
that that checking that SIL committee
committee process
we've got cabinet members we have
witnesses
and we have Tom Barker as one of our you
one of the witnesses or you you and
Christine who will be their hip of the
see lights and there'll be other
officers who will appear later on who
will be introducing or answering
questions about other papers so I'm
moving item eight to the start of the
meeting so yeah so before we come to the
first substantive item we have apologies
and substitutes please yes good morning
and I have received apologies from
counsel at all and do we have any
declarations of interest please can we
confirm the minutes of our last meeting
can you you've all seen and I hope happy
with seen nods can come with a proposal
to accept the minutes of the last
meeting please counselor Osborn
counselor ears and all are in favor I
trust so right direction yes just a
couple of points these yeah I wanted
when I found that I thought should be
9.45 mid Suffolk member of the cabinet
and the baby members of the cabinet
could I suggest to change that they
agreed that both councils had discussed
pledging funding for the respective CA
for the next three years I think that
would be more accurate statement of
their intent because it was it's not
actually been agreed by those cabinets I
understand that thought from reporting
to them to say that you've found they
had discussed citing funding for the
receive tok thank you thank you
is that the only the only change our
cursor I was born yeah thank you mr.
chairman is it just a clarification on
declarations of interest
I put declaration on that I am
on the outside body for the district
council as an observer with the Citizens
Advice at Sudbury I'm not a summary
Sudbury councillor that sits on on on
Citizens Advice I do it purely as an
outside body for the district yes that's
fine thank you thank you
okay so with with those with those
changes still got we're still happy well
we'll have to go back sorry counselor
McCraw can we have a proposal that we
accept these amended minutes counselor
counselor Caston you are seeing God
nameplate counselor caster is proposed
and counselor model is now seconded so
are we now is still all in favor please
thank you very much have we received any
notification of petitions in accordance
with the council's petition scheme
please received thank you are there any
questions by the public none received
thank you any questions by councillors
and he received in advance
none received you thank you very much so
now we come on to item 8 instead of item
7 which is the community infrastructure
levy expenditure framework review and as
I said we've got members of that review
body here that Joint Working Party so I
think cabinet member from baby is going
to introduce this item briefly please
answer Aarthi thank you Thank You
chairman yes this is the first review of
the sill expect story this isn't this is
the second review in the first review of
the sill expenditure scheme which Baber
and mid Suffolk approved in March of
this year members agreed to review the
Civic spending to framework and the
communication strategy after bid round
three and whilst bid round four
was in operation so that any amendments
to the scheme would be considered by
both councils and be in place before bed
round five which is made 2020 it was
also agreed in March 2019 by both
councils that the joint member panel who
informed the content of the SIL
framework and the first review would
remain to inform the second cill
expenditure review the second still
expenditure review has started and we
had our first meeting of the new joint
member panel last Friday
like the first sale expenditure review
it is important that overview and
scrutiny are in its at the start of the
process to afford the opportunity to
look at how we work with others
particularly parish councils and
community groups but also the
infrastructure providers to collaborate
collaboratively deliver infrastructure
within communities so today we've got
with us some witnesses to help we call
witnesses that's why I'm sitting up here
but I'm also the cabinet member for
planning of course for baby so to
introduce you to the witnesses we've got
Robin Morley here on my right who's the
parish councillor in Cocke field and
those of you who've been involved with
SIL over the last year or two will
probably remember that cot field have
been particularly successful in their
SIL bids and I think they're a very good
example of how SIL can actually help in
communities where there's an
infrastructure deficit so they're in
need of infrastructure there are no
other ways to provide it and so they've
been particularly successful with with
their bids and hopefully Robin will grab
to tell you a bit about that I was going
to introduce Steve Holman from Network
Rail but I understand he's been delayed
by a train being late or something um so
he's not here yet but hopefully he'll
join us later on I've got James cutting
here from the County Council
representing education and passenger
transport improvement infrastructure
responsible for person to transport and
and approved bid in Appendix C and I'll
try and get these two guys right Daniel
I think it's the one with the longer
hair
it's Daniel Turner and the man with the
interesting beard is Chris krischell
from the Clinical Commissioning group
responsible for the extension to bata
style health facility where there was a
SIL contribution of approximately ninety
nine thousand pounds towards half a
million pound project
I'm sure you've picked all of this up
from your papers as I said I make the
introduction as one of the two cabinet
leads for planning but also as a member
of the joint member panel both in its
first iteration and in its and in its
current form and of course I've also
been involved as the board member for a
number of parishes including Cobb field
where they've successfully bid for four
district sealed funds the report that
you've got in front of you gives you
background information on the timescales
for the joint member panel meetings the
dates of the - all member briefings
which are coming up for all members of
both councils the first one being on the
25th of September and gives you details
of the approved bids for both councils
and some assemble earning points since
the last review thank you
do the officers want to add anything to
that you members are you happy if we go
straight on to hearing the witnesses or
do you have any questions of what we've
heard so far we're happy to go straight
on to hearing the witnesses thank you
very much
so our first witness is Robin Morley who
is parish counselor for [ __ ] field
parish council you could press you read
press the button so your red light comes
on that's great so when you ready thank
you I'm pleased to be able to come along
and put a parish perspective on this on
the silt payments as a parish with we
have grown about 20% in the last two or
three years and we're quite a rural
village quite spread out village but
we've always tried to be active we've
gone for local needs and we've tried to
provide for the school and in the shop
and and try and improve the
infrastructure but we found it quite
difficult with with finance over the
years we've always spent our 106 as it's
come along we've put our precept up
considerably to try and improve things
whereas a lot of parishes decide the
best ways to keep their precept down so
I don't agree with I think you need to
go to the people to improve for the
village and we've been very active on
that Clive was our member and he's been
excellent I have to say and that we're
not just back slapping various people
here today I hope but Clive has been
excellent because he when sill job came
out he encouraged us to go for it he
explained the process he told us what I
would apply to and we looked into it
and we were put in various bits in
various rounds and we've been successful
we've bought two piece of land one about
three and a half acre piece from the
diocese for allotments very protracted I
have to say dealing with the diocese but
we did get there and we
and that's in a really good spot for the
village
we've also bought similar amount of land
which is for amenity dog-walking within
distance to the school for the kids and
we bought that as well and that was
after Suffolk County Council part of
that was to include a bit of dishes
railway line and there's a non Victorian
between Calvert there and we bid for
that to have some work on that so that's
going to be restored into the bargain
we've also put in a bid for refurbishing
the village hall kitchen to extend that
and improve that and again we will
success with that so we've been quite
diverse and various project rather than
just look for one big figure and I think
that's where sale has been really good
for our community as far as dealing with
the with Baber
we went through Christine furlough and
and around Firth and we found them again
to be very informative and cooperative
with our beets and so really you know
just to sum up you know we've we've been
successful with bidding for about fifty
eight thousand pounds over the four
beats and it has spread and it's done
really well for us but I think and I
daresay you will review how you're going
to distribute so but I would ask you not
to forget the communities because the
communities are changing quite quickly
in certain areas with increased housing
there's a change within the parishes on
how things are carried out they used to
be a lot more shall we say local
community work now money does talk in a
lot of cases and and I would urge you to
support the local communities because if
we're if we're going to continue to grow
and prosper we do need support with
money anybody got any questions of mr.
Morley
which we cast a melon Thank You chair so
as a parish council you've had quite a
bit of development so you would have got
your 15 or 25 percent automatically are
taking you don't have a neighbourhood
plan no we don't we so we get up we get
15% the 58,000 you talked about how much
of that is automatic how much is that is
is the bidding into the the other SIL
pot the ones you frequent could you just
say that again please
so the figure you gave us how much of
that money is money you got
automatically and how much of that was
the bids into the the other process well
what we've been what we've been given is
fifty eight thousand and and we've put
in forty thousand so that is by preset
and some outstanding 106 money and in a
small amount of our own sale money so
and what we're looking to do with our
ongoing drip feed seal money we're
looking to do a project on some fly
equipment where a lot of the development
is going to be carried out thank you any
any other questions yes certainly do
just to be clear with the top field bids
they actually mopped up all of their
outstanding 106 recreation contributions
so they're all now been used as robin
said they used some of their preset
money so they used some of their own
budget they used some of their own
parish seal and they topped it up with
SIL from the district pot so it actually
came from a range of sources if you like
thank you
so our our next review I think you are
our next our next witness have you got
anything that you you want to say and
now as witness
not not too much you'll be glad to hear
but the first thing that I'd like to say
is that people who are trying to access
SIL funds the very best thing that they
can do is they're not on the very best
thing that they can do is is have a word
with Christine and her team everybody
that I've spoken to who's been involved
in in bids in my my current ward and my
old Ward before the review they've all
said how useful it's been to get advice
help guidance from the seal team in
Preston Samaria where they were looking
at a village hall extension Christine
came out to one of their evening
meetings I know that Ann Herod went out
to [ __ ] field to have a look at the
various schemes that were being proposed
there I know that there were some people
that struggled initially with Syl and I
would say that one of the things they
should have done is that they should
have spoken to the seal team there's
guidance available on the website that's
been revised a little bit since its
first format but the the thing that I
think is most important is that if
you've got something that you're
thinking about have a word with the team
to see if it's eligible have a word with
the team to see what other funding might
be available certainly in community
projects you can get help with things
like outstanding 106 and with other
sources of funding because we don't want
to delete our sill pot with with with
projects that should or could be funded
from elsewhere and lastly it's not
really as a witness comment it's more as
a cabinet member comment but I would
like to congratulate Christine and ask
her to pass on our thanks to all of her
team because the setting up sill in the
short time frame that we had for the
original framework was quite a challenge
it worked really really well Christine
and the team put in a huge amount of
work to manage meetings at very short
notice I think we had about six meetings
over three weeks we're now on the review
and Christine
is attempting to do a similar thing
again we're on a next review and that
seems to be going okay we'll find out
when we come to our next meeting at the
end tomorrow isn't it Christine so but
it is it's a lot of work involved trying
to sort all of this out and I really
would just say to Christine please send
on our appreciation to all of her team
thank you shall we move on now to James
cutting from Suffolk County Council
Thank You Chet
my name's cutting head of planning
Suffolk County Council on my team deals
with section 106 and civil
infrastructure bids and we liaise with
other colleagues within the County
Council in terms of bringing those
projects forward to fruition the
committee may already be aware that the
planning practice guidance states the
charging authorities should work closely
in setting priorities for how Silver's
spent and and we are already doing that
with babyman Suffolk we have regular
monthly or sometimes weekly meetings
with this little team in setting out how
projects that are going to come forward
and working together on programming the
the projects and the stages that they're
at and then after we are obtaining in
the funding when there's going to be
delivered so that there's good
communication going backwards and
forwards I would highlight that we need
to be careful that what's set out in
paragraph 449 of the report which is but
of course it largely agree with but but
we don't and Stan ditional bureaucracy
to the overall process and and it has to
be focused on the different
stages in delivering infrastructure
being the being not another chance to go
over the merits of a particular project
or some of the other details that are
there are different stages throughout
the county councils process where there
are engagement there are opportunities
for engagement through the same process
as well but there are stages where
decisions need to be taken and ands at
that point those need to be made and the
silh process shouldn't be in a rehearsal
of some of the other details the
decisions that are that are taken but
but we're largely working through the
the programs that we have got and we're
working through the the points we are
finding not necessary difficulty with
but when with when you're moving to a
new process and when you're engaging in
different forms of infrastructure there
do come come questions from local
communities and also from officers and
we are working on and undressing that
the points that that erased and our
regular meetings that we have do to do
that but in setting up a new structure
for civ expenditure and just need to
always have in the back of our minds not
to make the process too - too cumbersome
and and bureaucratic the the
relationship between Scylla and section
106 is changing changes to regulations
now mean that
the charging authorities must set out
where they're anticipating the the
funding for different types of
infrastructure to come from and what's
known as double dipping where you have
to spend sil money and you can't charge
for section 106 that has now come into
to an end but we we still need to be
quite clear about where we expect
developments to be contributing such as
to new education infrastructure or the
relocation of schools in terms of
schools as well
projects that start through basic need
funding so the funding that we get from
government to offset the cost of
background growth not additional growth
has come from from housing but
population change and some projects
start through basic need funding and
then because development was it has
occurred and after that funding has been
secured we're including some additional
places and so so that there's the
structure of the expenditure needs to be
mindful that there is this funding part
and from from government and that still
expenditures is a part of it
the any other aspect that I would
highlight this whilst we are highways
and education we're also the lead local
flood authority so there will be
opportunities for water management and
flood alleviation
thank you very much thank you are there
any any questions casa Grandin Thank You
chairman
just the still money provide some of the
extra things that on top of government
central funding you know the sort of
nice to have board does or do you have
and are you instructed are there rules
on how you spent the money is it or does
it go on fundamental things
provision you know how are you able to
spend the same money as you wish on the
nice extra things to have or are you
finding you're having to use it for the
more central fundamental understand I
mean you know they're fundamental with
the bus stops for example there are
certain standards that that we have and
it's a pretty standardized format and
also with education infrastructure it's
a pretty standardized product that
you're producing you're not gold plating
taps there are some aspects that from
government funding and the way that the
Department for Education produces its
guidance means that we we do need to put
some additional resource into different
forms of design that allow us to
maintain the school
for a bit easier and the there are very
different technical details that go into
the different funding pots for four SIL
there is yes greater flexibility but we
have to justify it and and as long as we
can understand and provide that
justification at the right time then
they're nationally any problem at all
thank you there's a question I think
from cancer the field thank you
I'd say basically I think the things in
my County divisions they've got a built
out so far
probably 106 funded but nevertheless
we're getting close to civil and these
processes are taking extraordinary
amount of time on things you can put up
four or five hundred houses much more
rapidly than you can pull out a school
extension but nevertheless things get
done the thing that concerns me is
sitting in on planning meetings and
things always is that my impression is
that the total still available from a
number of these developments is less
than the cost of putting up a single
school extension in other words to me it
looks as though the amount of money is
grossly inadequate I wondered if you'd
like to comment on that
thank you council field for allowing me
to provide that opportunity yes we would
of course like to see a better
relationship between the the amount of
money that's that's coming in from
development and they are in fact the
cost of providing the infrastructure and
this is one of the reasons why we say
that new schools and early years
facilities should be funded through
section 106 because the cost from SIL I
think no matter where you are in
countries is not sufficient I I do know
that your officers are reviewing the
the levee and that will be in line where
with the local plan with you but of
course the the specter of viability that
does does come in for four schemes that
we are not able to completely rely on
SIL we will also be looking towards
justifying through the government basic
new funding and if we can't get that
then it comes back to amusing RM
reserves which is not something that the
County Council is able to do throughout
throughout the county so that the the
aspect that I think this committee needs
to be aware is that SIL is there to
provide a lot of flexibility for
infrastructure but for some critical
features that are absolutely necessary
to provide sustainable development the
section 106 is still a much better
source because you're making that direct
relationship between the development and
the amount of money that you're
expecting and it's then not such a drain
on the sill part so so the SIL
expenditure can can provide for some of
the aspects that the local community
would want to see as a benefit from
development not just as a necessary
thank you um Tim Barca did you want to
add something to that answer that reply
I just just wanted to come in on on that
point and I think due to the
complexities of the whole system and the
way it hangs together at the
relationship between section 106 and
sill and the recent changes to the
regulations are probably not kind of
possible in this committee to rehearse
the whole argument but they think it's
important to recognize that that sill
does allow for some balancing out so
they will inevitably be some
applications that come before planning
committees whereby the infrastructure
requirements are going to cost more
than the SIL is generated from that
particular development there are also
inevitably applications that come
forward and which are granted that make
a SIL contribution whereby there isn't
actually any infrastructure cool
there isn't any call on those in that
that money that is generated from that
given development so for example we
wouldn't be able to collect any money
for infrastructure from developments of
one to nine dwellings through section
106 for education and all kinds of
things like that whereas sue does make a
contribution for every single dwelling
house that comes forward on a square
meter which so it both constrains some
of our activity but also gives us more
fragile freedom and flexibility and
opportunity to generate money beyond
what we would otherwise be able to
generate through section 106 so there is
some some balance in our in a mobster
and it also provides the opportunity
whereby and and I'm not disagreeing with
Jones I think there is a section 106
does give you certainty but section 106
also requires you to forecast ahead and
use various formulas and expectations so
a hundred dwellings will generate X
number of school children well under
section 106 you make that forecast and
you secure a given amount of money for
that well if that hundred houses
actually generates twenty percent more
children who need to get in schools your
amount of money is fixed so you don't
get any more through that process if it
generates twenty percent less then
theoretically you've got more money than
the demand actually required so SIL
allows you to understand what the actual
impact is once you're once you're
determining what the cost and the
infrastructure required is rather than
having to kind of forecast ahead five
years sometimes and guesstimate what is
going to come from a given development
so there's give-and-take within both
approaches and I think some of the
changes that have recently happened to
the regulations give us more flexibility
and it's incumbent upon offices and
other colleagues to work out how best to
use the range of tools that are
available to make sure that we are able
to facilitate the kind of optimize the
contribution towards infrastructure from
any given development Thank You
councillor Mansell thank you I just like
to ask that a bit of confusion on my
part perhaps that is the Suffolk County
Council education infrastructure people
who who comment on a planning
application to say that there needs to
be an extension to the local school but
if that local school is not in County
Council control its an Academy what is
the I mean is it the Academy you have to
apply for the CIL money or is it what is
your relationship with that education
provider that isn't controlled by the
County Council anymore a good question
we still retain the overall strategic
function in those cases so they the the
role that we do in responding and it's
my team that responds to playing
applications is when something comes
through we can get the facts and the
figures from the education colleagues if
we identify that there's a need for an
extension our education colleagues
couldn't and talks with that Academy
straight away we we also do the same
process for for local plans so if local
plans allocating a site we need to have
an extension to a school we secure the
the agreement from from the Academy and
that's come up actually in several
inquiries of inspectors there's gone
have you gotten a greeting from the
Academy the process then for for bidding
is with the County Council and we work
alongside the
I mean mr. Smith Abids the the Academy
is effectively then the the project
manager but we are securing the the
funding bid and and quite often
academies do appreciate the experience
that our education team has got and they
don't have the skills in-house
themselves in order to deliver an
infrastructure project such as that
thank you
catch them the crore thank you chair
James I just wanted to ask a couple of
questions one little notice that in the
introduction to it references the bids
for bus stops but of course from the
impression I'm getting is we're not
really talking about Suffolk County
Council primarily focusing on bus stops
those are fairly small ticket items I
hope therefore route services that will
continue to be in service I've found an
abandoned bus stop the other day lovely
beautiful brand-new bus stop no service
however putting that aside I'm getting
the impression now we're looking at
larger ticket items but possibly not the
full ticket items that would be normally
dealt with under section 106 how large a
sort of bid
do you anticipate Suffolk County Council
having to put forward on Seoul and do
the proposed changes in the framework
meet your needs in providing that
infrastructure thank you crow I will
avoid the bus routes issue it's it's an
understandable shot but I will remain on
that point if you're putting in
infrastructure that doesn't mean that
something can't
later or can't can't have some other
some other function and but we are we
are working on targeting the the the
right bus stops in the right places in
terms of the scale I don't have to hand
the you know on top of my head the scale
of the forthcoming funding it's in total
but would but we are looking at projects
of multiple millions in in some cases so
we're talking four or five million for
an individual project so it is big scale
and when it relates to the development
that has occurred in that area we can
justify the requirement for that and
scale of funding the I know I'm sure
your officers will comment on this the
critical thing is to be able to project
manage the and that expenditure and
align it with the the costs and the
commitments that that we need to make so
we we can't go out and procure a someone
to go and build some infrastructure if
we aren't certain that we're getting the
funding and we are working on on that on
that process and of course there may
also be delays or in in in certain
projects through whatever reason and we
are we can alert and your authority to
do that delays as soon as we can that
can you able to program your expenditure
a little better and and just have it
follow on how does the proposed
framework meet your perceived future
needs
I will reiterate the comment that I made
at the start we need to make sure we're
not making bureaucracy so the framework
is it does does meet our needs but but
what we can't have this is the framework
functioning as a point where the the
merits or this specification of a
particular piece of infrastructure then
get fully rehearsed at the point in
which we are applying for the funding
that needs to occur earlier on in the
process and if we're providing an
expected program of infrastructure to to
both authorities then then we can work
through and identify at which stage
those decisions are made and how much
engagement that we need to to take for
those different infrastructure items so
that we've we're answering those
questions before they even come to the
to the funding station Thank You
councillor Fleming I think you had a
question yes thank you chairman my
question relates to I expect you all can
guess what my question will be about
about the expenditure on bus stops I
think the matter has been raised but I
would just like to say that just looking
through their papers the immediate thing
that struck me was 46,000 pounds has
been allocated for instance to bus stop
improvements in Stowe market now if the
seven routes coming in and out of stone
market five you know considered
vulnerables over the county council and
will probably stop functioning come
November and I see repeated instances of
money which is very scarce these days
being put into fantasy bus stops and
shelters when the real problem is we
don't have
the buses to serve them does our sole
framework allow us to try in some
respect to remedy this situation
the bus service may come on in the
future whether if it becomes viable for
whatever reason authors changing and
funding you you would then need to be
having those those those bus stops put
in place and they're also existing
services that will flow along routes and
that investment will be made on bus
stops along those routes as well in
order to encourage more people to be
aware of the services and and and and
use them it is a challenge and it's one
that my passenger transport colleagues
are working on to target and be more
precise when they are putting in and the
request for funding at the planning
application stage that is relating to to
a bus service but that but but that's
but that's at the planning application
stage and as mr. Parker is pointing out
and things things do change and and SIL
provides us with that degree of
flexibility so there-there is that it is
a stage in which we can review and that
the framework does provide us to ask for
different bus stops for example or
remove those that and that we had
previously requested thank you did you
have a follow up question yes what's
happening to the money that has
currently been allocated to bus stops
that won't be either adequately served
by buses or served at all because
there's quite a lot at stake
I can set out if the committee too does
wish our process in writing but what we
are focusing on is getting those that
bus stop infrastructure - it relates to
development and a and the services that
we we will expect there to be when when
we do review the services sometimes that
is after the decision has been taken for
that for putting in the money for the
bus stop which is regrettable but we we
are working on aligning the the future
request for bus stops to to this
services that we are more certainly
under gonna be existing in the future
thank you I think we're in danger of
losing track of what we're really here
to discuss Tom Bergin's did you have
another question point yeah sorry
Christine may have been seeking to make
the same point but I think it is
important to recognize that SIL the
community infrastructure levy is a
mechanism to secure money for hard
infrastructure no longer and revenue
costs so I think your first question may
have been alluding to whether SIL monies
could make a contribution towards
supporting those subsidized services
that they're removed it can't it's it's
it's only the physical infrastructure
itself that it can provide for Thank You
Kristy thank you yes
responding to earlier comments that
James made it's very good to hear that
the work that we've been doing
collectively and in terms of
collaborative working has been producing
a program and we've been devising how we
can deliver infrastructure projects
where we've seen growth happen so it's
important to get those started I think
there is a balance to be struck however
between James's comments about not
wanting to add more bureaucracy into the
system I totally
understand that but at the same time
from our point of view the SIL
expenditure framework only deals with
bids where they come forward and as
we've been hearing today there is an
awful lot of work that happens before a
bid is submitted and where we're
spending or could be potentially
spending multi million pounds on
different projects I think there is a
need to make sure that we have the
correct governance and processes but our
ambition there is to make sure that
whatever is put in place through the SEL
expenditure framework works as
effectively as all the different
governance arrangements that all the
infrastructure providers have and I
think as well with with the review that
is now started and is ongoing we've got
to respond to the fact that we have a
joint Local Plan which has growth we
have an infrastructure delivery plan and
we have a policy LP 31 which focuses on
infrastructure provision and it's the
infrastructure that is important to the
communities in terms of delivery so
everything that we're working towards is
to make sure that happens I think the
other thing we need to ensure is that
when we're spending SIL we must make
sure that we have best value for the
money that is being spent so again you
know there is a reason to to look at
these things and to work collectively
with our partners thank you are you
happy now that we move on to the next
the next speakers so is it going to be
the doublet or Daniel is Daniel Turner
and Chris Chris or whether you're going
to both speak that would be great thank
you
Thank You chair so my colleague Chris
and I we are here representing the
Clinical Commissioning group as the
commissioners we are responsible
health in the health cross Suffolk and
we also have a secondary function for
responding to and dealing with the
planning applications and bits for
sillim 106 monies primarily state for
primary care GP contractors we've
developed a very good working
relationship with Cristina team and have
been heavily involved in commenting on
the local plans and also developing a
pipeline of work that we can put forward
through the civil process as you can see
in the report we had a successful bid
with the Box Dale project this was a
scheme that's been worked through the
health system which is quite an arduous
process to get funding through
I'll lean forward and see the foster
cell project and we were successful in
98 thousand pound of so money this went
a long way towards a half million pound
project for the Bosto health center it
allowed us to create five additional
consulting rooms an additional meeting
space which not only helps the local
population with the growth they're
having but also allows the GPS to bring
in other services and I know the live
meeting room they're looking to develop
close relationships with the local
hospices and create more of a community
project GPS in particular are a bit of
an anomaly in the health system in that
they are private businesses and NHS
funding we are only able to fund sir
proportion of development work which
means that GPS have to establish the the
cost for the rest of it themselves so
we're we're able to secure sill funding
towards that that aren't not only
reduces the burden on the NHS also on
the GPS cost they have to put in which
means they can look at providing more
money in to actually running the
business rather than developing the
infrastructure
I I just like to say that I as as a
planning officer and planning support
manager for the CCG we've been working
very closely with Christine's team and
worked on the infrastructure development
plan and as part of that we've been able
to look at the proposed development and
to look at how we need to develop our
strategies and our premises around that
but as my colleague was saying these
properties GPS are private businesses
and so as mr. chitin was saying that
with the academies and things like that
we have to go to them and they have to
be supportive as well and it's not as
easy we don't have control of the
development in the term we can only
advise and then they have to they make
decisions based on whether they've got
the funding or whether we can get
funding and that's where the seal
process comes in very helpful because
it's able to take some of that burden
away from the surgeries and we were able
to discount that amount off of there we
have to pay a certain amount hspace a
certain amount and the surgery pays and
the leftover but what the seal does is
take that amount and reduce it and so by
working through that we're actually able
to get schemes that would never be able
to go go ahead in the first place
because a lot of the surgeries don't
have the funds available for large
schemes so the sillies really really
useful for that thank you could I just
ask with that project was was there a
sort of a community element to its sail
community infrastructure levee its you
weren't just put what was provided was
not just provided for a medical or GP
reasons what was it is there some
community space within there you you
refer to community
in your presentation so primarily the
space has been built to alleviate the
growth in population for the GP practice
but the GP is quite for thinking and as
I alluded to they are looking to engage
with the community and look they have I
can use that space in different ways so
they are engaging the hospice and they
run groups for mothers and babies so it
should create a versatile space thank
you so it does have a community element
to it as well so it can be used by the
community Tom just just as a point to
clarify there I think for the avoidance
of doubt the provision of GP places is
perceived to be community infrastructure
so in the same way as Syl bids could
provide for new school places that
wouldn't necessarily provide for dual
use facilities for the wider community
or anything like that education
infrastructure is community
infrastructure GP practices are
community infrastructure so it doesn't
necessarily have to have a supplementary
element that provides for meeting space
or community drop-ins or anything like
that the the space itself would be
appropriate without those other
ancillary things so that just just to
clarify that point yeah thank you for
that I'm just getting the feeling that
if there is a community element to a bid
which is primarily for something else
like Stowe upland high school there was
much made of all this there are
community elements to this development
and so that should help us get the Syl
contribution but that what you're saying
is it would be relevant without any
reference to any use by community for
any other purpose thank you thank you
and this is probably for Christine or
Tom so I've got 98 thousand how much of
that was boss Dale's own part and how
much was the the wider community porn
the money came out of the local
infrastructure court it didn't come out
of any ring friend
funds and it was one of it's been our
only health bill bid so far across both
of the two district councils and when
SIL went live that project was quite
well developed and it was a company it
was an opportunity really for for health
to apply for money for something which
are the people in our parishes would
have been travelling outside the
district quite some distance in order to
get palliative care but we understand by
providing everything that has been
described it's allowed our residents to
to not have to take that that journey
that make that distance thank you I've
got councillor fielder then I think tell
Moses do you want to add to that thank
you sorry just to supplement that answer
I guess one of the things that this
review of the framework can usefully
explore I think just reflecting on a few
of the questions is that relationship
between the 15 or 25 percent that goes
to the local community to spend on
infrastructure and that bit that stays
with the District Council to be able to
allocate and the the way that we
developed the relationships with our
parishes so that there is a kind of
collective contribution to
infrastructure that is important to a
particular place because I think
probably too often it's been a sense
that the district part has been used and
the local parish have also had a
contribution from their local sale that
hasn't necessarily gone into a
particular item in infrastructure I
guess with the GP surgery even in
question that could get complicated
because it will serve 15 parishes
possibly more and so who contribute
somehow or might get bit complicated but
part of this review will explore that
relationship between the local
contribution and the district
contribution and how they both which I
think will become increasingly important
particularly where there are more
neighbourhood plans where 25 percent of
the money is going to those local areas
those local areas there are some
parishes
they've probably now received in excess
of 100,000 pounds and that can make a
significant contribution towards
multiple people all put in their hand in
the pot and kind of grow in the overall
pot getting an external funding those
kind of things so that absolutely needs
to be part of the process that we're in
now Kristen do you want to answer we
must go to several members then just one
thing that is a subject which is going
to come up at the SIL member group not
only tomorrow but the the third session
that we intend to have so that very much
is on the agenda Thank You counselor
field are there to next it's just the
NHS as you point out the clinical
commissioning groups of private
businesses I just wondered once the
infrastructure is constructed this title
remain with the NHS or does it become
the property of the lucky GPS so the
clinical commissioning groups is part
the NHS with the GPS who are the
standalone businesses it depends on who
owns the estate the so GPS are unique in
their position within the NHS that some
of them own their own building some
least their building is privately some
weaknesses and from the NHS so depending
what the ownership of the building is
will depend where the ownership lies
afterwards if the GP zone they're
building they will only at the end there
is a way that the NHS debates
reimbursement on that so that we don't
pay for twice thank you your Kirsten
Lacroix thank you mr. chairman I'm sorry
that the councilor field was finished
but as I understand it because this has
been a perennial question in terms of
infrastructure provision and in the past
people have always asked if you haven't
got a GP surgery in your village the
question every time in the application
comes borders can we have a GP surgery
and you have to make the explanation
that they have to want to come from what
I understand you're suggesting with
actually for the first time we have a
direct method of mechanism to bring the
GP
maker GP coming to a particular
community a little bit more likely is
that a fair assessment or spare summary
thank you it's a difficult point there
is a shortage of GPS nationally NHS
England hold the the reins on giving out
new contracts for GPS so it's it's
really working with the assets that
we've got we can make the improvements
to increase provision which will
hopefully be more attracted to
recruitment so in fact it's just
somewhat theoretical at the moment
because fundamentally it needs to be
something needs to be there already yes
that's fine thank you very much more
thank you I've got councillor Mansell
thank you um I'd just like to ask about
the amount of money that you got from
the CIL pot which was just shy of
100,000 slightly less than 20% of the
whole project cost and I just like to
know whether that figure was the same or
similar to the amount of money that we
told her a planning committee is needed
for the developments in Bott Estelle and
its surroundings towards the NA towards
the GP provision I mean it's that as
similar money is that what was it should
have been earmarked from developments
less than or more than because it's only
20% of the total project to that well I
can I can offer some comments to that so
this project that was brought forward by
the NHS at the time was not something
that was responding to a planning
application it was responding to a
deficit in need of GP facilities in that
area particularly as I understand it
with reference to palliative care but my
colleagues behind me will correct me if
I'm wrong initially the project started
off with us being asked for half the
money so
20,000 was the original Silbert however
through process of looking through the
business case and understanding what was
being proposed there was quite a lot of
equipment and telephony and other
matters involved in what we were being
asked for it's important to remember
that silly is only used for
infrastructure it's not used for
equipment and so therefore we negotiated
a situation where we could fund 20%
because those were the eligible items
and that was sufficient still to land
the project Thank You councillor Mansell
I come back on that I mean we are told
when we're determining planning
applications that the NHS has asked for
pots of money a certain amount of money
to for the local health primary
healthcare provision so you know I hope
have we are any of those coming forwards
because clearly bottle isn't the only
place where there is currently a deficit
without the extra burden of the new
development so it's it very interesting
to know that they've applied for some
see our money and got it and yet all the
ones that are deemed to be needed due to
the development that we're getting
haven't yet applied for it who was to go
first the answer is yes there are other
schemes coming forward and so that the
NHS process for getting a scheme through
is very long-winded
and complicated so we are proposing to
put more forward for steel bids
it's just lining up where the projects
get to to the right stage with when the
bid rounds come through thank you Tom
just just a conscious that I believe
colleagues here are from Geneva CCG so
just before you get into any forensic
questions about force it
no no but just unconscious that
facilities within your area within will
first in elves well and that general
area would be the West CCG so don't
these guys to feel put on the spot in
terms of understanding particular
schemes when they're actually in another
CCG area yeah I think I think we've
covered this this topic this this the
CCG enough can we we've got one one more
witness who has arrived and that's Steve
home and so can we hear from Steve home
would please Thank You chair I was
delayed by train ironically but it
wasn't so thank you very much for this
opportunity to to speak to your new
members I'm the Business Development
lead for Anglia route in Network Rail
and my job is to deliver third-party
funded projects for Network Rail to work
closely with our partners in local
authorities and the private sector to
bring forward investment in the railway
Engler happens to be one of the highest
performing routes in network rail in
terms of securing externally funded
projects so in the five years to 2019 we
secured four hundred and fifty million
pounds worth investment on our railway
network in Anglia our target for the
next five years is four hundred and
fifty million and we're working very
closely with officers and in local
authorities in particular - we're
working on 6/5 bits which are
multi-million pound bids across the
region and we're working on a number of
Silla plication and too numerous to
mention section 106 applications so
we're geared up to work with your
offices in delivering externally funded
improvement - enhancement on the railway
are there any councillor McCraw sorry
mr. chair
as a keen user of Railways aware that
they cover a large number of local
authorities so when you are actually
applying of putting bids together are
you producing bids for multiple
authorities SIL funds are you separating
them out or are you just looking for the
location where a piece of an
infrastructure might be particularly
placed well in other words there's one
Authority bear the full consequence of a
Silpat councillor McGraw thank you very
much typically we work with groupings of
local authorities in relation to bid
some of these bits of very large
multimillion-pound bids so if to be
honest we it tends to be on the larger
bid a grouping of local authorities or
LEP's
or combined authorities but on smaller
pieces of infrastructure or a smaller
improvements that might be a single
Authority that we're actually working
with thank you any any more questions
so are we happy now to progress to
debating where we take this and what
what we can come to recommendations and
so on so who wants to kick off right
cancelling the curl I do apologise after
I think I warned one or two members I
might say something this is an again I'm
going to echo something councillor
Aarthi said one of the first things that
new councillors elected in 2015 dealt
with was the preparation for the launch
of the eventual sill structure or I
remember Christine at the original
explanation to our Sigma and counselors
we get fed everybody was be ignorant of
SIL in those days we were still learning
and it was the preparation that is now
paying off because this is the third
stage of the bidding and I have to say
that as the pro processes this is the
second time it's been descripton e this
is the second year it would have been
through the the worker gate was called a
working party or no joint member panel
got it now but the whole process the
process of the bidding and the changes
and development of SIL is exactly what
was predicted all those four years ago
because it the start it was it was
foreseen that we would start off with
relatively local bids based upon
individual communities and that's
perfectly typifies but by robbing over
there with bids for [ __ ] field and the
early stage of bids it's also terrified
by the smaller scale bids of Suffolk
County Council for example bus stops and
it's clear as was suggested that
eventually the SIL pot gets bigger we're
going to have larger projects we are
going to be dealing with other sources
of funding and they're going to get more
and more complex and that's the reason
why this framework needs to develop now
fortunately we've been given some
flexibility in the one to three lists I
so I commend the work of Christine's
team commends the work of the member
panel because it's fairly obvious over
the process and I'm talking a four year
process now that the process has been
well planned and that we're as well
prepared as we can be for something
that's fundamentally a wider than how
long is a piece of string question
there's so much to this but it answers a
lot of questions that weren't being
answered elsewhere so just those points
throw them into the pot because
generally speaking I think this is a
nice piece of work everybody involved
should be commended yes I agree with
that I've got I've got
the queries if it you have reports back
of how much has been spent of the sale
money that you've given out is that
roughly on track of how the right that
you would expect it to be spent I'm not
talking about the right it would be
allocated but our once they once the
money is allocated to a particular
parish council or whatever are you happy
that it's being spent at the sort of
right it's not being hung on to so the
infrastructure is coming out coming into
use very quickly that's one query and I
have another query around the the
infrastructure development planning in
in four point eight I think it is he
talked about of the first is what was
they consultation on the infrastructure
development plan how often is it is it
reviewed and is it reasonable as you
suggest here that that parish pips of
projects within parish pips should align
to the infrastructure development plan
okay so in terms of when we allocate
money are we spending it
you'll recall that all SIL bits have to
be oven-ready schemes and by that it's
meant that they have all the necessary
formal approvals so everything is ready
to go if you look at appendix appendices
B and C you'll see that a lot of the
projects are started or well underway I
only know of one bid in particular that
stalled because of a party rule issue
which needs to be addressed and another
bid which is being reviewed other than
that the the progress on all of them is
moving forward so from a delivery point
of view that needs to be that seems to
be working very well in terms of the
infrastructure delivery plan we worked
on that collaboratively with all of the
infrastructure providers in fact all of
the people that you see here today are
the people that we've been working on
that document with it is a collaborative
piece of work before we published it in
July we had five iterations of that
because as fast as you you home one
element of work you need to then look at
another and some of these things tie
into each other which mean that you need
to go backwards and forwards and of
course what's also happening is that
this doesn't happen in an arena where
there's no change changes happening all
the while as far as infrastructure is
concerned so in in terms of how many
more iterations there will be I think
there will be as not as many as we need
to do in order to keep pace with growth
as it goes forward it is an iterative
live working document obviously we're
not going to change it every week but at
particular stages alongside the local
plan then it would be our objective to
make sure that that document is you know
as grounded as it needs to be to
for the local plan as far as the
planning infrastructure investment plans
are concerned as you'll recall this was
a document it's an informal document it
has no statutory basis there's there's
no reason why parishes need to fill this
out I think when we launched it we said
it was really a conversation starter in
order to understand what ambitions local
parishes had in terms of the
infrastructure that they needed and it
was to bring us a little bit closer
together with the infrastructure that we
were providing for those communities
from a strategic point of view as well
as understanding the local priorities
and we are continuing to work on that
basis with parishes to understand what's
important to them and it's not all about
what can be delivered through SIL there
are other external funding pots that can
be used there is community grants
there's external funding there's parish
precept and it's about trying to assist
parishes with signposting as much as
with active delivery whether those
projects where they they do strike a
chord with the IDP than they would
clearly play into it and as Tom said
earlier the conversation really about
where we've got a lot of now developing
neighborhood plans with a lot of money
which has already gone out through
neighborhood sil there's every reason
why we need to talk about how we can
deliver things thank you can I make a
plea on page 24 and 4.9 as effective
communication with the parish and ward
member at an appropriate stage can I
make a plea that that it's not it's this
isn't some of the districts it's
something really for a county to take on
board we had a very unfortunate incident
in here yesterday when a planning
application which really probably should
have been approved was not because the
ward member wasn't aware and the ward
member could have given some guidance to
to those who were promoting the project
and where there was a conflict between
the county and the parish that could
have been avoided if the
remember had been kept informed - I play
really what you need to involve the ward
member for any any big project it's not
up to the the seal team to do that I
think it's up to it's up to the
infrastructure providers to keep ward
members both county and district ward
members fully involved because they can
probably help you see the project
through rather than hinder it thank you
that's the scarf Thank You page 26
relates to the method for the collection
of the monies for the SIL regulations
2018 it reminds us that those parishes
that have a neighborhood plan received
25% and those that don't receive 15% the
regulations are they prescriptive in
terms of the cap into four parishes that
do not have a neighborhood plan because
there is a 100 pound per property
allocation and so that is ring fenced
out that rather than 15% of the toka
steal monies so other regulations
prescriptive or is that something that
the district has adopted I think that's
an easy one to answer they are
prescriptive we have no discretion over
that are there any other comments oh
sorry I didn't see if so a counselor
granted thank you Kevin I think I
probably should have asked my question
earlier at the previous stage so I
apologize for that
um I'm not perfect for Christine or for
the network rail gentleman but with the
rail type SIL monies we as far as I can
think in babe only have one railway
station and is it looked at when you
look at the applications
how much it's going to benefit the
people in the district it sounds like
we're talking about quite large sums of
money but with only one railway station
we're not that well served in in our
district in this aspect so how much is
it actually benefiting and do you
consider that aspect councillor Grandin
thank you for that question
the station you're referring to would I
can you just let me know which station
eight Sudbury that's an interesting
station Sudbury because it's it is
connected to the the greatest and main
line of course at most so we deal with a
lot of proposals to build new stations
which are quite expensive or to improve
stations we have to take into account
the benefit to all railway users so
passenger passengers and freight that's
particularly important in Anglia the
freight usage so we do look at the
benefits of that sort of station
improvement or a new station in terms of
the benefits of the people in the
immediate area but we have to balance
that against the potential dis benefits
to other railway users because as I
think someone else mentioned in relation
to bus stops a stations only as good as
the services that are actually stopping
at that new station and so a new station
will have an impact on other users and
the timetable for those users so we take
into account the immediate geographical
benefits or costs but also the the much
wider impacts on on the usage of the
railway and and we also have to look at
the impact of any improvement scheme for
example a station but it could be
something else in relation
to our long-term planning and our
medium-term planning for the railway so
we we are not focused in on just the
immediate beneficiaries of the station
we have to look at the wider impact and
benefits on the railway system thank you
Tom Barca just a supplement that answer
I guess worth reminding councillors that
bids that come forward for rail
infrastructure are likely to be greater
than 10,000 pounds therefore they're not
delegated to officers therefore they
would come to cabinet for a decision on
those sill bids and I would imagine that
it would be part of cabinet members
consideration to understand the impact
and benefits for their residents in
agree in those Silver's so is a decision
for cabinets and I would anticipate that
cabinet members would reflect on the
benefits for their residents balanced
against wider considerations that the
infrastructure provided themselves and
might feel as part of any bids Thank You
counselor field
thank you I too forgot to ask the
question of which representative and one
of you indulge me I was just going to
check whether there is any independent
audience of your estimates of cost of
rail infrastructure improvements
particularly mindful of the I think the
salient thing when I was on the planning
application and underpass to take her
foot way from one side of the railway to
the other was guest a million pounds and
I say guest it was a very earliest it
man I believe that estimate is now five
million pounds which seems you know an
almost hs2 type level of increase that's
even bigger and obviously it's awfully
easy to make silly guesses about what
those some should be just question is is
that just your one staff that produces
those estimates or is it independently
audited in any one counselor field thank
you and so I think there's two parts for
that question um in terms of the the
governance that
projects are subjected to at Network
Rail we have a process called grip that
is shorthand for governance for our
investment projects which is a gateway a
stage gate decision-making process and
there's eight stages to each project and
we use that to manage and mitigate risk
for the project all types of risk that
performance cost safety and so on and
that tool is is embedded in Network
Rail's way of working and it's also
connected to our internal governance
procedures so we have a panel an
investment panel Anglia that scrutinizes
all projects during their life cycle and
during the grip life cycle that we've
that they are subjected to I actually
sit on one of those panels and we review
the the work of the project sponsor that
includes external externally funded
projects so the short answer is yes we
have a very robust government process
and investment control process and
that's important for for projects on the
railway they do tend to be a bit more
expensive and that allows external
funders to to see transparency about the
risk management and also where the
accountability lies for those projects
so that's the first answer coming back
to thirst and I do know that project
reasonably well I have been working with
your officer in Christine in particular
the two values that you mentioned were
for two different types of project so
the 1 million pound estimate which is in
2014 wasn't for a foot weigh tunnel it
was for works to bring the foot wave
under the railway bridge in a safe
manner where's the estimate which I
think you're referring to have 5 million
pounds is to actually construct a foot
weigh tunnel through
Blankman I think they're two slightly
different that that would explain the
difference in costs on that on that
particular project thank you uh customer
cause to speak then I think we we need
us a committee to decide what we're
going to put forward as our
recommendation thank you Jeff it was
just actually on that point would have
silh bid in such a case not be required
to be oven ready and therefore have been
through a full examination by civil team
is that correct Christine with the
different regimes that the
infrastructure providers have so we're
well aware of the grip procedures but
that's pretty much part of this review
process already yeah thanks I think
conversation with I think that clears
the point that remark would be well
thank you so no okay
has anybody got a propose that they want
to put for we've got some
recommendations here which we can either
take or we can completely change I think
that there is a feeling that we want to
commend the work of the SEAL team as
well as just know the contents of the
report so counsel McCraw do you want to
put some words I just thought were a
couple of things that were worthy of
noting in that this has been a part of
the process that we've been looking at
methods of methods for SIL to be first
the bidding rounds that was something we
largely dealt with at our meeting last
year the six monthly process the
refinements that have been added to the
SIL process um I'm hoping that people
making bids have found that that has
improved the experience for them but the
second point of course is the second
part of this the purpose of this review
is to improve the framework for the
disbursement of the spending of the
money and I think in both cases it seems
clear to note that the process is
working as it was intended to do and I
think it's important to make that that
there is visibly improving and we're not
just noting that we can
they say that we can see that the work
has been handled well that the process
is improving and it can continue to
improve and the only other thing is is
does this committee wish to take a
further report at some future date that
those were the two recommendations I'd
add but we need to put a timescale to a
report back I mean I personally don't I
think that that team will come back to
us when they feel that their there are
changes which will need to go to cabinet
and we should have a look at beforehand
so if we can put some sort of words into
what council McLaws said that we Twitter
said we've we understand
recommended we can hope you've got some
words brilliant a fit and proper process
has taken place in both aspects of SIL
and I think that's the purpose of
absolutely committee is to see examine
as to whether a fit and proper purpose
has taken place and I think we can say
quite clearly it has can we use some
words on that Henrietta do we want to do
we want to agree every single word or
are you content that after the meeting
we'll put those words together in a
couple of sentences and if that is the
case we have a proposal do we have a
seconder thank you Karen
right and is everyone in favor of that
thank you very much
they say thank you for that endorsement
when we set off on our original one-cell
framework and then we did the document
it was very much on a socket and sea
basis and we knew that it would need
review and review and ongoing review so
you were very much part of that process
and thank you very much for all of your
input and rest assured we will take all
of your comments into consideration
thank
so we just have a minute or two to and
have those who have attended this item
him don't wish to stay for the rest of
the meaty that they might like to I saw
sure could I propose
you
Thank You members we were just about to
to resume with we're now moving on to
item 7 which is the route changes to
waste collection and only fares who is
the corporate manager is going to
briefly introduce this can I say right
from the very start we've all had lots
and lots of emails and telephone calls
what we don't want to get do is to go
through them any of them certainly not
all of them because we're all aware that
there have been problems in some areas
but what we're trying to do is to find a
way forward not to look back and say
just how bad it has been for mrs. Jones
up the road is that ok
Thank You Olli I'm Jeff so before you
today is the report on the rain changes
and on the 15th of July we went live
I've included in the report the
background information to give some
context as to why there was the need to
do there and that mainly revolves around
the house and growth we've seen I've
gone through the Tom's approach to the
report how we went about it what the
lessons we could learn from doing that
in in the future and generally the
communications approach worked very well
we had a just a handful of return flyers
and once we got over the first week
really very very few queries regarding
what days the new collections were to be
made on I've gone through the
implementation phase what happened when
we went live and there's some statistics
in there around missed bins and call
handling I've got some latest
information for you on miss bins as of
this morning we had 48
outstanding miss bins cool levels have
now resumed to around the hundred a day
which is back to normal levels an
average wait times and for the last week
on calls were two minutes and nine
seconds which again is lastly there's
since I've tried to summarize what we
did in lessons we can learn moving
forward very well Jeff thank you very
much I mean what we can do perhaps to
help understand the futures if there are
any other lessons that we think that we
picked up that they could they could
have learned who can implement then then
us that's helpful
cancer Grandin thank you Kevin
I I think the reports extremely
well-written very clear and lists all
the information I believe that we need i
I think it's a very good report I think
the whole move over to the new days I
think has moved very smoothly and was
very well organized in my area of Hadley
I have had no one report to me any
concerns they may have been concerns but
I haven't had any reports of such I
think the whole thing has been handled
extremely well and I'm also glad to see
that we're not bearing the costs for it
my only concern in this report has been
the cold waiting times because to me
that should have been a predictable
situation and it should have been an air
away could have brought in it could have
been mitigated by bringing in extra
staff just to cover that period and the
week beginning 22nd of July it appears
that you had around
15-minute wait time and I think that's
unacceptable
particularly in when it was probably
predictable that that would peak them so
that was my only concern but I think the
rest of it has been handled extremely
well in my opinion so you know I'd say
well done
apart from that aspect thank you thank
you do you want to respond to that Olli
yeah Thank You counselor oh yeah I I
have to agree that didn't catch us oh
really
I mean over that period we support our
existing pool team with other men's of
staff from the waste team and we didn't
have any holiday but during that period
but the level of calls yes that did
catch me up with ladened in hindsight I
would have had additional resources
there yes absolutely
yes take that totally thank you I'm
gonna take questions from members first
and members of committee first and then
others after that if that's okay and I
think I had counsel handing him next and
counseling McCraw so cancer having him
thank you thank you so much I have had a
few problems but you've always dealt
with them very efficiently and quickly
and I want to say thank you for that but
what I have had is some people from the
my parish council saying um why can't
all recycling breathe national why is it
different in every district wouldn't it
be simpler if everyone could just
recycle and put glass and their bins
like they do in Norfolk and stuff like
that and also could everyone have a
sticker because it was the new one tetra
Paks that you know can't throw out
because their recycling is going
elsewhere that lots of people are still
just you know throwing them out
apparently and just even if you tell
them they shouldn't they think they know
better
and anyway delete foot drops I think at
least once a year about what they can
accomplish it would probably be a good
plan or a sticker they could actually
put on the bin to remind themselves and
their kids and everyone else's using
those bins but also about the national
thing yeah I think there was an
opportunity a fly was coming out there
could have been a
but the reminder on the flyer that would
but that's easy with the benefit of
hindsight
so them thank you and in terms of the
national strategy that is something that
government is looking at at the moment
there's some consultations able to look
at having a much more wider generalize
recycling scheme across the country
because you're absolutely right it
really does vary very much from district
to district in some areas at least
within suffered we have a totally
consistent approach and the glassine the
way I've have been confuses a lots of
people so yes a more consistent
approaches of the ways offices with them
welcome as well and in regards to
communicating that message about what we
can we start being especially after the
changes yes that is something we can
look at I've been sticking campaign none
of this is cheap
unfortunately so it is always that
balance between cost and benefit and
generally most people do get it right a
lot of that information is available and
we can provide it to be included in
parish newsletters so perhaps there's
other ways we could do that love and you
know Universal poster Kinberg it's still
getting the message out to people that
don't look at those things Thank You
chair Olli I noticed on page 15 of the
report that 528 missed weekly
collections at the peak and that's
referred to later on however looking at
the customer contacts in the period we
have a peak of over two and a half two
thousand phone calls now I appreciate
some people are going to fill more than
once and some of those phone calls that
we missed but the 528 figure at peak
falling eventually to a figure of moster
258 or even 94 depending on which
I take that's the ones you know about
and my question is have you had any
method of feedback by speaking to the
new binman the rounds
I've heard of one Road a parent Hamlet
that was completely missed off I'm not
going to go into the details that's for
you to deal with in your routine but one
team one complete Hamlet apparently was
missed off the new routes and I know I
informed you of some cases where a whole
street didn't get done no familiarity
with the rounds will get rid of some of
these but have you taken any feedback
from the delivery of any collection
crews to see what their perception of
this has been in other words in in order
to feed the process back from their
experience into into your usage of their
though of their workload you understand
what I'm suggesting thank you I mean
that feedback is constant the surco
screws when we feed him back to their
management they will be feeding that
back to us a lot of cases they would
come and talk to us directly you're
absolutely right they're the guys that
are out on the ground delivering this
service so they know what looks like
what doesn't like where things are where
things are missing so we've managed to
create a dataset now of where we collect
form what we collect but as with any set
of data it's not perfect bits are
missing roads have dropped off systems
and as you suggest a hammer so all of
that feedback is constant and that goes
to improving the system and making it
more robust moving forward I understand
also there were some informal local
arrangements that disappeared when a
crew moved somewhere else and that was a
real shame because obviously they didn't
have the opportunity to let the new crew
know that that old lady drowned the
corner she tends to forget to either bid
was just behind the gate there that sort
of stuff is actually human and you know
it's a human business
yes Thank You chairman um it's actually
to get back to councillor Grandin's
comment on the length of the telephone
calls I'm given to understand that when
a resident actually booked or identified
and logged on to the online system and
said I've got a missed collection they
then rang to find out or to confirm
whether or not that request had been
received which indicates to me that when
they completed the necessary fields
online they didn't receive something to
say thank you for your request it will
be attended to immediately and that in
turn would have reduced the number of
calls coming through maybe not by a lot
but it would have had an impact when
you're when you've you've got a funnel
situation okay thank you thank you
cancer Caston I've got next yes it's in
regards to the telephone calls a
15-minute waiting time have we collected
data on when the peak times were of
those calls and is it possible that we
could um we could have some kind of call
back arrangement when it goes quiet
maybe in the afternoons I I'm assuming
that the people would be the the main um
waiting would be done in the mornings
when people realize their bins haven't
been collected and they em and they're
looking for AM information could we have
a system where we we tell them one
person deals with them and they get a
call back later on to just spread the um
waiting times across the day
thank you our tall system we use is
excellent data capture and will it allow
us to analyze data I'm not an expert on
it so I don't know what level it would
enable us to do that I certainly take no
suggestion onboard and yes that that
more them to be able to flatten out
those spikes perhaps where the message
would would have been helpful again I
think what we've witnessed here is at
once in a generation or spiking calls to
the waste office and and business as
usual it's a very manageable steady 100
calls a day that you know sit quite
nicely throughout the day so yeah
business as usual it's very manageable
but I think moving forward a lesson to
be learned for anybody that's doing
something like this again is going to
generate a lot of tools
yeah there's certainly something to
consider yeah thank you
Kirsten McClaren oh yeah I didn't
receive any complaints from any
residents however from the parish
councils
in-store world were about the efficiency
and the capability of the vehicles being
used was they reported a lot of
breakdowns during rounds and then the
vehicles had to go back to wherever and
sometimes didn't return and they the
question was being asked are the
vehicles fit for purpose because they
felt that the amount of waste being
collected was in promise more than was
originally in the original rounds
Thank You counselor it's quite difficult
one to answer with in terms of the
vehicles are certainly fit for purpose
they are that is what they're designed
to do and the bulk of our fleet
there's 16 plate vehicles are relatively
new so they are generally very reliable
however saying that it doesn't mean that
they don't break down they do an awful
lot of work and there's spare vehicles
available and given this period we've
had spare crews as well sort of on
standby if you like to mop anything up
so yeah that is a bit of a surprise to
me that crews did was broke down and
nobody appeared which was stuntin which
impacted on Holbrook because I I'm not
sure whether the route was but I think
he sort of made its way to it the crews
made the way towards Holbrook after stun
and I think it was them that were
actually getting the you know the result
of the of their vehicles having to go
back and it was more than once and twice
because they mentioned it I guess it
you've got some feedback on where the
vehicles might have broken down and and
in your review of how it went with with
the contractor I guess this these sorts
of things will already have cropped up
so I guess that you'll be aware of that
but you did have you did have vehicles
and crews on standby so if there is a
problem then Mike I would hope that
that's already been flagged up and it's
all been dealt with but you know I had I
have no
no complaints at all in my patch add one
one query about why why do we see
vehicles in our village more than one
day a week but that's because that's how
the roads have been reset but absolutely
no problems at all Council McCourt just
to note that the report covers seven
weeks to the last week of August and I
just wonder what improvements might have
taken place since this report was
prepared all of the periodic covers as
it continued to improve and in what ways
Thank You cancellous so as I alluded to
earlier miss beans this as of this
morning
when I left the office there was 48
pools have reduced now back to normal
levels hovering about the hundred a day
which is business as usual and
call-waiting times the average last week
was two minutes and nine seconds
Thank You councillor Mansell you had a
query thank you no I would just like to
perhaps elaborate on councillor Adams
comments about about the communication
that went out to residents because I
personally I do think that there was a
missed opportunity that our the one
that's on our website their thing about
how do you do your recycling could have
been incorporated into the leaflet that
was telling people they had a change of
collection day because recently I've had
a lot of queries and saying why can't
they post anything why can't we get a
list of what goes in the bin we're just
putting everything in the grey pin which
is something that we certainly should be
discouraging but I so I think that that
was a missed opportunity and it's a pity
that that didn't go out at the same time
because that would have been then funded
we wouldn't have to pay out again to
deliver to a load of houses but it's
interesting that the only people who got
the information were the ones who had a
change to their collection day which in
your report was sixty-five thousand I
wondered how many what is that in report
of the number of households cuz I've got
no idea how many house and presumably
that's across both districts because
although there were people who had a
change of collection day there may have
been others who had the same day but
because the round still be changed
instead of being picked up 7:00 in the
morning there were picked up at 3:00 in
the afternoon they may well have
complained but not actually been aware
of the fact that there were any changes
at all so I just wonder what the
proportion was that they would went to
the houses and whether it wouldn't have
cost that much more to have told
everybody that there was going to be
some changes and what you put in every
cycle Thank You counsel and the 65,000
that had a day changed that was out of a
total of approximately 84,000 we debated
whether to send everybody a flyer it's
interesting that went were a few did hit
the mat and face we've told somebody
that their day was the same as already
was we receive complaints about what
wasted money again what we discussed it
when we felt the leaflet we sin L was
was very to the point that you know your
collection days changing in the
collection calendar on the back we had
two sides of pay for available to us and
and we took a decision by absolutely
take it on board that any opportunity we
could get to get that recycling message
and what goes in the vibe in we should
be doing that Thank You mr. chairman yep
first of all can I just say that the
amount of calls that we had weren't very
many and however having then taken them
on board we then rang
who responded exceptionally well to all
the problems we had the one question
I've got for him which also from the
previous speaker is about the the way
that the recycled and general waste is
dealt with I'm afraid it's not good in
Sudbury in terms of I've over the over
the years had to keep repeating to Circo
or waste management that they're not
doing what you're asked for and
therefore some of those bins are not
collected because the bins will not be
emptied if it's in the wrong being order
or there's been what they call it
infiltrating with waste which shouldn't
be in that bin so I agree with with
councillor back that we you know we do
need to clarify a little bit harder with
some of our residents particularly
around the subway area
I speak for that area because a lot of
bins get left because of the way they've
been are not recycled all put gent to
general waste but all of that I much
much want to thank the waste the waste
team for they've done I think as an
excellent excellent work Thank You Olli
yes thank you I've got a few points to
make but in general clearly you know
you've got through this once in a
generation thing very well and so
definitely commending you and one of
your team Hannah bridges I was looking
at he's responded very well to several
of my inquiries about missed bins I
think the thing is that when people had
a miss bin and they reported it and they
didn't feel confident that that's when
we heard that there was a problem you
know it was or two or three steps down
the line but in general obviously those
those have reduced to almost nothing now
so I've got a couple of points it's a
question about the routing of the calls
when people were pressing that option
for the waste management
I understand all those calls were going
through to Stowe market where there
wasn't enough people to cope and how
quickly was that sort of re routed so
you had extra people to help then again
picking up on the sort of multiple
reports thing where you've got a street
that's being missed and you know almost
everyone is ringing in and and it
doesn't seem to be the confidence that
they were getting the feedback that
something was happening I think that
that point that customer VC made so
that's an area where I think the
feedback somehow needs to be improved we
had an issue in one of my villages with
where the green top bins are missed and
then a week later the recycling was
collected with the other rubbish which I
know we've had an email back and forth
about and I think you told me then that
that was sort of pretty much the crew on
their own initiative just trying to
clear up but then we've had other
reports of that elsewhere so I'd like to
know how much of that went on and was it
definitely kind of road crews doing that
or was it something that happened
perhaps more often than we'd like
and then lastly is question on the
cruise obviously I was used to seeing
the same crew come round in my village
and they knew the village that kind of
local knowledge thing when you read
redeploy to the new route did we make
sure that that was maximized that that
people were as far as possible kept in
the same area so that that local
knowledge wasn't lost Thank You Kara and
I'll deal with the recycling being put
in with rubbish because that certainly
isn't something ever sanctioned
something it just goes against
everything we're trying to achieve and
I'm afraid that during this process with
the volume the bins there was a few
incidents ways where that did happen
moving forward wouldn't expect to see it
at all
we've have on the back of this looked
our own processes so when we flag up a
miss bin where our flagging up really
clearly the commodity is so there isn't
room for error
I wonder where it wasn't so clear before
guys were seeing a Miss bin rapport not
knowing what they were going to collect
and so emptied any bin they saw so off
the back of this we have tightened up on
how we post this information and with
regard to your second point that
knowledge sort of sat within circo's
operational krob and up teams and I
would have expected and I know they did
share some of that knowledge so spread
out some of the crews across patches
where they could you know where you had
this local knowledge that you would have
otherwise lost I think probably it could
have been handled better and that could
have been spread out more undoubtedly I
think a lot of the issues we've had and
seen are those little bits of snippets
of local knowledge that only the
existent crew might have known and yeah
some of those did get lost along the way
and there's caused issues that on the
region you've caused so as I alluded to
before you that that massive Pape did
catch us unaware you know I have to put
my hands up to that it was all hands to
the pumps doing that really busy week
and calls did get lost and you know
unacceptable waiting times so again with
hindsight and if we ever do anything
that it's a game you know absolutely we
need to be clever about how we deal with
oh it's general point of information
well counselor melons kind of covered my
original question and good explanation
of that but I just like to say that like
to do the changes on this scale okay
there has been disruption but there
hasn't been an absolutely huge amount of
disruption considering the size of these
changes and these changes have made what
we're doing they're more efficient more
environmentally friendly they Verma the
you know we it's fantastic what we're
achieving already with what their waste
services for the cost to the residents
and how it works we've just we've made
them even better you doing this we're
using less fuel we've got vehicles
driving less distance to UM go to
different routes it's some really good
and I think I'm I feel a bit of sympathy
for youth so I've been in front of
scrutiny answering questions on them
15-minute waiting times on telephones
and when I think we've got to say that
this overall has been a great success
we've it is regrettable no one should
have to wait on the phone for 15 minutes
but that's that's changed now it was
some it was a lot of disruption but to
deliver such a big change you know good
job you managed it very well yes put it
into context I was talking to somebody
and I said oh well the worst point of
your changeover that was so much better
than we get week by week in our area
that was somewhat different part of the
country so yeah you've got to put into
context just a very
short point on that very point if you
were one of the 528 missed at the peak
it was 100% failure if you were one of
the eighty three and a half thousand
people who got there been collected it
was 100 percent successful it's just a
matter of perspective Thank You
counselor having him did you have
another point yes it's just a bit of I'm
possibly gossip but we just got an email
this morning saying that some of the
people might be being put up in the
Holiday Inn yes that is that is correct
yes so there's some relief drivers that
certain to cover this period to mop up
additional miss spins and just to be
there as a catch-up crow again that they
brought them in from their Milton Keynes
contract and this stone at the Holiday
Inn claim might add at circo's expense
absolutely yes Thank You councillor
Osborn Thank You mr. chairman and first
of all I'd like to in doubt endorse what
councillor Castor's said I was going to
say that myself but you beat me to it so
but no absolutely endorse that the other
thing that it raised as part of this
change in process was those properties
that have been given planning permission
that are down a lane where the refuge
collectors can't get to for whatever
reason so could I just ask this
opportunity to put in a request please
that when a planning application comes
forward for properties to build be built
mainly on background development where
the our waste services put in comments
to that planning officer in regards to
accessibility from waste collection
vehicles I've got a case in Sudbury
where an elderly lady lives down the
track which it takes in about three
minutes to pull her bin right up to the
end of the track it goes up a hill so
when it's bad weather it's icy she's
already slipped over a couple of times
we cannot access her
so she's been told that she can either
bring a black sack up to the end of the
track track or she can bring her bin so
obviously that's one that's been and
gone but if we could address that in the
future to make sure that comments are
put forward to the planning officers on
the accessibility to those properties in
regards to planning applications coming
forward Thank You mr. chairman
thank you okay you want to respond to
those I'd just like to say that my
officers do look at all planning
applications and yeah we have an
opportunity to come in and obviously the
to be able to get a refuse truck so the
bidding collection point is yeah it's
fundamental seven paths parent to
deliver the service Thank You Council my
Vaizey next Thank You chairman and
picking up on cancer Osborne's point
um and Ali's point when you look at a
map you might think that's fine we can
get the vehicle down there and done but
the difference between looking at a map
and dealing with the reality of a farm
lane or a rural Lane and I think council
Osborne's point is very very pertinent
moving forward on our environmental
agenda because we do live in a rural
area we do have isolated people people
who are isolated and unfortunately many
of them tend to be older and less able
to take their bins either down the track
or up the track so we need to consider
that in the entire planning process I
think that's terribly important I concur
with everybody else in respect of the
report that's being produced is very
good and it was a very good service and
we will be having to revisit this
because we are building houses so in the
years to come I'm sure
we will have another but we've been
through the dummy run now and we've
learned from it and I think every we
also have to take it on to be aware that
this took place in an unprecedented
spike of heat which we as a nation are
not very good at handling so if your
bins not collected and it's 30 odd
degrees and you can't open the front
door or the back door because the air
coming in is hot tempers get a bit
frayed and expectations are may be a
little excessive okay thank you
I've got councillor Grandin is there
anyone else I can ask I'll have to
cancel the grounds and thank you yes
thank you um I was only going to say
that going back to the implementation of
the new rounds I think it needs to be
really even though we've talked about
where things have gone wrong it's
actually such a small percentage and I
think it can it can and should be
regarded as a very successful change
that you've made to a service that for
some people this is how they see their
council tax being spent it's the most
important aspect of the council tax in
their view because it's something that
they feel they're paying for every week
and and it's the most important thing
most visible thing that that gets done
with their council tax as far as they're
concerned so it's very important to
everyone so I think the the percentage
where things have gone wrong is very
slight really in the overall picture so
I think here the service and and the
implementation of these changes really
needs to be commended the other thing I
want to say
that we're very lucky in that we have
such a good service having been to other
parts of the country and other parts use
services in Europe and I hope when you
mentioned earlier in your introduction
that there may be changes because of
looking at how things are done
nationally one thing I and many people
like about our particular service that
we have in our district is that it's
very simple it goes in one of two or
perhaps three bins and and it's simple
and that's not the case throughout the
country and so I hope that it's more
likely other parts of the country will
move to a system that we have rather
than us becoming having a more complex
system so I hope that you may recommend
that our system works successfully and
that we don't have to adopt a more
complex bin system because also not
everyone has the space in garden or
wherever to store large numbers of bins
and and once it becomes too complex the
system I think could become less
successful thank you I'd like to commend
the way it's all worked Thank You Kass
the scarf please thank you and in the
financial implications then all the
direct costs associated were covered by
Serco but as always there are indirect
costs which presumably would have been
covered by this council which we which
we won't be able to sort out
I think circa probably learned a lot
from the exercise and I'm interested in
the phrase business as usual in your
financial implications there's no
penalty at the moment for surco there
will be in the new contract but surely a
company as large
Serco business as usual always involves
changes to collection rounds in
different areas so I'm wondering whether
we should be looking at penalties within
the new contract that would cover this
kind of situation because it appears to
me that we could go through this kind of
situation again and the financial
penalty is currently in the new contract
will still not apply so the set of kpi's
of SLA s that we've negotiated into the
new contract do cover things such as
miss beans so for not responding to miss
been there would be a financial penalty
but isn't in the this existed contract
that runs until 2021 but but there'll be
no financial penalty if in a changeover
have been routes because that will be
something which is an abnormal week or
two I guess we I mean we enter into
these this arrangement as a partnership
and you know it was widely recognized
that it would be disruption so yeah that
would not be business as usual so yes
you know we would suspend normal
business as usual penalties during such
a massive change for a reasonable amount
of time Thank You councillor Vaizey
Thank You chairman and coming back to
councillor Grandin's comment about the
simplicity of the system here in in
Baber
mid Suffolk very much to recycling is
dependent on volume and I talk albeit a
long time ago I actually worked in
automotive waste an automotive waste was
waste oil and bumpers and how you could
recycle them and you think bumpers are
made of plastic well they're not they're
made of a huge range of different
polymers but the benefits of recycling
are hugely dependent
getting the volume throughput and I
think that whoever decided the system
for this area of the country was very
far thinking because where I lived in
Warrington surrounded by industrial
towns you were able to I to split your
waste streams and get the volumes
whereas what you've done here is you've
been able to identify recycle it that is
not dependent on high volumes but you've
got a system of taking it in and turning
it round to the benefit of the community
which i think is to be commended to
those who had the vision and the
foresight to create to implement the
system that you have that we have yes I
just know of AZ I think the more we can
keep it simple especially in a largely
rural area the better and I know that
Holly and the Suffolk waste partnership
are working hard on that point as we
respond to the government's you know
white paper on waste isn't it a
consultation on the future of waste in
this country which is a really important
consultation or series of consultations
I just like to just reiterate my thanks
to the team and you know to say how you
know thank you for their relative
overall great success of this change
which you know obviously there have been
a few glitches so what well done
I think the areas where things went a
bit wrong were largely a human factor
issue and there's always a human factor
and that's where I mean the human factor
is important we don't want to be a fully
automated world so you know a few
mistakes here and there it's worth a
little bit of pain
to know that you know another year or so
will recognize our bin men and be able
to say hello to them and you know maybe
remember them at Christmas or whatever
we're not supposed to do they're also I
just on the paper and in paragraph 7.1
on the risk but I just wanted to query
the highly probable and very high risk
of failure of long-term service delivery
due to increased housing growth I'm not
sure that I I'm not on the committee but
that I would agree that there is a
highly problem high probability of
failure yeah especially given the
performance we've just seen in our
capacity to adapt just one more final
thing I wanted to say was that Wyndham
earth and the material recycling
facility reopens which will be quite
soon won't it that you know everyone
will have a chance to go round it and
see it in action and it would probably
be a good opportunity then to put out
some sort of flyer to everyone
announcing you know the fact that we've
got this new facility any opportunities
for public interaction or you know
visits to it and to you know restate the
types of recyclables that people can put
in their bins
thank you I'm taking a counselor crow
and cancel them all after counseling the
court and then I think we need to just a
point of information I suspect that the
likelihood an impact on the risk
management was actually if we had not
carried out the review and relates to
the process that was existing under the
old system we would have been then in
danger of it being highly probable that
there would have been problems and in
fact what we've had now compared to the
problems we would have had had we tried
to continue
I suspect we would have had a very high
impact much greater than this temporary
blip cosa Lula Thank You chair really
question for Olli
we've just we'll used to produce a
monthly magazine received as part
residence we
gonna do it on a coffee base I know that
Caitlyn well um they produce one for
snow upland bearing about quite a lot of
cases here mention the fact that
reminding people about what they can
recycle that would you be would you be
prepared perhaps to let us have an
article which we could put in that
magazine which will go Roma Street as
part of two thousand residents as a
reminder it was sunny welcome you at
what you need to do that that's a
fantastic way for us to get information
yeah just an open invitation anything we
can do to help you get information out
there and I think if that's in the if
that's in the form of a safe flyer or
something that can also put people and
unparished websites that would be
excellent I'll take out so wall boys
because he hasn't spoken yet and then
we're going to move on to try to come to
a recommendation thank you first of all
I'd like to thank Oliver and his team
leader David Atkins I in I had a very
pleasant interaction and courteous phone
calls with you and the problems I had
with with in giving of Ward will very
quickly I was particularly pleased where
follow-up calls and emails were made
because I thought that personal contact
was people who are already a little
feeling a little bit frustrated was very
important I do need to apologize on
behalf of one of my constituents who
made it I think from his reported
unpleasant phone quarter to you I think
your operators must have had a quite
stressful time dealing with these so
they're my sympathy I think all the
points about sort of the collections in
the ongoing system have been have been
dealt with very effectively and I think
your reporter is really very very good
I think the recycling issues is going to
be a long-running debate on whether it's
going to be split out further or do you
Bay and that take the councillors
comments about the throughput has been
very important and that there's two
things itself just now got my mind this
sort of diesel lorries I mean the
environmental aspects of actually using
diesel to power the collection obviously
the problem itself I think they do about
seven miles to the gallon so perhaps
looking at alternatively power systems
in the foreseeable future might be
interest I think they are schemes run in
Scotland the second one is is the sort
of benefits of outsourcing the drivers
to cerci is that having a partners are
keeping things in-house would that not
simplify things that's is a matter that
has been debated and there has and over
in scrutiny have had to look at the the
best way forward and I know that we can
return to a debate about whether we
should move the service in-house or we
should contract it out we'll continue to
contract it out because that that debate
has already been had I think yeah
yeah so is there is there anyone who
would like to suggest something more
than the overview and scrutiny panel
knows the report I think I think we
could at least thank them for the report
and commend the work that there were
waste management team did in handling
what we have called and we believe to be
a successful introduction of the new bin
collection routes councillor McGraw can
we suggest that the learning points from
this experience be forwarded to the to
SLT for future projects that might have
a similar range of changes I think the
reason to send it to SLT senior
leadership team is that there are likely
to be here for longer than any of us can
be sure we will be here after all we're
talking about once in a generation okay
there are there longevity is perhaps
more predictable
yeah that's reasonable and there may be
other changes to the way services are
are delivered which there may be
something from these learning points
that can be used in another another part
of the different service so so if we add
that I would work people generally happy
with what I what I said at the start and
then we also add that learning points
before worded to senior leadership team
are people happy with that is anybody
prepared to propose it Thank You
councillor handing em councillor grant
and thank you and are we all in favor of
that please right well can I do thank
you very much can we just thank you only
for coming along immediately from your
holiday and thank you for the work that
you've done and take our thanks back to
to the team thank you very much
the offices are on the way to talk to us
about the information bulletin members
later Kevin
no no have a talk around the way that
the work plan the future work plan
because I think causa res has got
something to report back on one of the
items that we had considered for the
work plan and if you'd like to give us a
report back on that then we can perhaps
look at the work plan very quickly and
see whether we may need to make any
alterations to either work plan all
right thank you very much councillor
well we had a really good positive
meeting on Monday and so much so that
we've got the next three meetings
planned and booked there the 9th of
December the 9th of March and June Yates
so that is all up and running the main
things that we found out were that we
need three transits science and and
there are three hundred and thirty
thousand travelers in the United Kingdom
and they thought its funding is
available here to help with transit
science we didn't elect a chair or a
vice-chair we'll do that at the next
meeting because we look we're looking
through the terms of reference and so
they're going back by the 30th of
September and so then that would that
will be agreed and we're going to invite
people from the various traveling
communities because there are quite a
few different sections to maybe gain
knowledge so that we have a greater
knowledge and understanding which I feel
we should have we have a new manager for
Suffolk and Norfolk called Ashley grant
and hopefully he will come to the next
meeting with meadows which is the
Ipswich site has actually been sold by
Suffolk County Council and they
have bought it themselves so that's no
longer under Suffolk County Council the
basic sights were looking for would just
be fencing and water I've done of your
veneers got anything else to add you
know please that everything seems to be
moving forward and you know I'm very
enthusiastic about it thank you
so I've come to the cows in the corn a
second if we if we if we look at Paige
at 57 for the baby with page 59 for the
myths up at work plan we see that
there's as two items down there for for
October on each joint meeting counselor
McGraw or did you decide I just wanted
to confirm that we're when we don't need
to carry on any further investigation
into this subject that it is being dealt
with by there would be the working what
is it working party or steering group I
can never remember what the titles of
these things are but whatever it is it's
being dealt done we just be duplicating
yes it wasn't in our work plan anyway so
we're not going to put it in the work
plan so has anybody got any comments on
the work plan where we've we have done
21st of October possible continued
scrutiny of CA is it still just possible
yeah we we're not I think I think the
question is now it's certainly not done
with it because what we're now at the
stage of and those chairs will be
contacting there are other constituent
councils today and tomorrow the report
out of our last meeting has been
prepared it's been put together initial
contact has been made with officers and
now we are getting down to forming some
sort of task and finish group as
discussed by this committee and as part
of our recommendations should the chairs
discovered that these necessaries of
bring it back to our next meeting we've
kept it on the agenda that may not be
necessary because it may be supplanted
by the task and finish group and I think
that might be the way forward
it isn't we still have it down on the
agenda it can easily be removed yeah
but if that isn't if we don't bring that
back to the next meeting we only have
one item on the agenda we don't want to
delay that item but we will be meeting
for just that item unless anything else
crops up in the meantime so I don't
think we can bring anything else forward
so I think the work plan is how it is
with the possible continued scrutiny of
citizen vice but if the time scale needs
to be if that needs to be brought back
later can't be much later because
decisions will have already been made
but that will need to be reported back
at some time even if it's a report back
that
we've we've failed to encourage
sufficiently other districts to join us
in their a wider joint scrutiny is that
fair house on the Gorgas I think that's
exactly the point it's quite possible
that we may have something to report as
chairs or the Working Party sorry I
can't call it the Working Party I must
call the task unfinished fruit yeah go
any council concerned about working
parties we've set up a task and finish
group at least that's the ideal and
maybe that we can report back on that on
the 21st of October and and just to
finalize things around the work plan did
anyone see anything on the forthcoming
decisions list that they felt needed
needed to be put into the work either
work plan and I personally didn't see
anything there that's the right point to
raise about I understand there's a call
in that John Madison has initiated that
has
know that there was a call in a request
for a call in from councillor Matheson
it was supported by a sufficient number
of other councillors it was discussed
councillor Matheson and I and the
assistant director and the deputy
monitoring officer discussed that and
the deputy monitoring officer was not
persuaded that there were sufficient
grounds for a call in and so the calling
was answer the request recording was
unsuccessful I have taken on board some
of the matters that were raised in the
callin and I have spoken with the leader
and the deputy leader about the reasons
for the request and the wider reasons
around of the request and to try to
avoid other requests along similar lines
so although it wasn't called in I think
some progress has been made as a result
of the request for the call in but if it
had been a successful request there we
would have had a mid Suffolk District
Council over in scrutiny committee court
at very short notice
that would be that would be the way
forward if there was a successful
calling of course if it was in labor
calling then it would be the baby
overview and scrutiny
unless hypothetically it was a matter of
interest both councils it was a matter
of interest to both councils
hypothetically it would have been a
joint
thank you so we've dealt with all the
bits and pieces that would be at the end
of the agenda we have only one item left
on the agenda I believe and that is the
inflammation bulletin on the
introduction of a continued introduction
of the Universal Credit
yes--it's item with debate is whether
it's item 9 item 10 is item 9 and
officers do you want to add anything to
oh sorry
cabinet member would like to give an
introduction that's fine Thank You mr.
chairman
yeah although the number of universal
credit claimants living in Baber and mid
Suffolk properties is steadily
increasing the numbers are still
relatively low despite this Universal
Credit claimants are accounting for a
significant amount of the overall rent
arrears in our stock Universal Credit
has undoubtedly created some challenges
for the housing service with universal
credit claimants and the Department of
Work and Pensions require a different
approach to the world of Housing Benefit
challenges include the difficult
administration problems that can
accompany alternative payment
arrangements the difficulties posed by a
national as opposed to local benefits
system and the limitations of the online
landlords portal
however mesh met measures are being
taken to improve performance and manage
the risks associated with universal
credit these include a new income
management policy an ongoing project to
improve our written communication with
tenants a greater focus on early
intervention with new tenants and
encouraging tenants to build up credit
on their rent accounts although it is
early days improvements in overall
collection performance in the last two
quarters suggests that the changes are
in fruit Thank You mr. chairman thank
you can I thank the officers for a very
comprehensive and detailed report which
is excellent as was the last report that
was presented the offices are leaked
crowded out whose attendant services
corporate manager and Polly Berman the
tenant services professional lead would
either of you like to add anything to
the information bulletin just very
quickly I mean I think counsel Osborn
summed it up very well I think all our
dad really is that overall I think team
performance is very good but Universal
Credit is impacting and I think as much
than you think it's it's a time issue
for us and the the amount of additional
time that managing Universal Credit
claimants and their rent arrears is
taking but I think without changes
through the income management policy
we've started to see some progress and I
think overall we're quite happy with the
work the team are doing but I think it's
really just for the the committee to be
aware that Universal Credit will
continue to be an issue for us and as
the number of claimants increases it
will become increasingly challenging I
think so is it a gradual increase in
workload on a sort of fairly straight
line graph or is it does it go up in
fits and starts I would say it's been
fairly steady so far looking at the the
increase from the February report to now
we've not seen a huge jump it is kind of
numbers that are manageable I would say
at the moment and I don't think we
anticipate any great leaps at the moment
that is largely down to central
government and you know their their
approach to the continuing rollout but
so far it's been fairly steady I would
say I'll invite members to comment or
ask questions but I think if if we if
there's any way that you feel that we
can help in the work that you're doing
perhaps that could come out during that
during the debate or the question
they'll be the reason that we're here is
to see if there is anything that we as
as a committee or the broader
councillors can do to help because we we
acknowledge that you're in a fairly
difficult position but you appear to be
managing it very very well cancel
heading did you it's a really
comprehensive and we completely
understand all your own problems and it
doesn't seem to be helping the fact that
you're losing your service innovation
leads and the whole problems with your
landlord portals and stuff I just have a
question and I'm probably a complete
idiot here well you've got the anyway
the appendix in Appendix A you've got
your universal credit rolled out by
parliamentary consistent constituency
what does it mean it says your area
ranked 34 so yeah that's information I
pulled off of I think it's one of the
central government websites come in
which ones voice but I think that's the
role that in terms of how far that
constituency has progressed compared to
all the other constituencies in the
country I think that's what I refers to
let me just oh sorry it's in the region
rather yes yeah it's the constituency is
that right yes yeah so sofa if we're
looking at the South Suffolk one yes Oh
13th in the region so in terms of how
far the role that has progressed and
then 186 in the country so so we can see
with South Suffolk actually you know
with some way behind which for our
perspective is a good thing
that's the look I'll just propose that
we do know to the report the question
only the only question arises is that
because this is a an ongoing situation
we received this report last how long
ago and the last report was February so
a six monthly basis appears to be what
we're getting and are you anticipating a
great degree of percentage uptake in the
next six months or should we delay such
a report for or say 12 months we're not
anticipating your great leap in numbers
but I'm more than happy to produce
reports on a six monthly basis if the
committee find it useful it's that's my
point exactly I just don't know if
there's any value to doing it at a six
monthly interval if the difference is
not going to be significant it's quite
clear that your team are in very well
under control as much as it is possible
to have something that is not under your
control in your control you have done
what you can we can't add any more by
examining every six months so I would
suggest that we do if you do see any
marked deterioration that at that point
it could be brought back to other view
and scrutiny but I don't see any need
for us to ask for a further report
unless that does happen that's precisely
what I was going to suggest yes so do we
do we need a proposal in a seconder for
that we do we just say that we'll put it
in the workload workstream twelve twelve
months time so thank you very much
but do come to us and if any any one
individual can help in a particular area
do still seek us out and I'm sure that
if we have any problems we know who to
come to but thank you very much for the
report thank you for the work that you
are doing councillor Osborne yeah if I
could just add another point to that I
think before the introduction of
universal credit and first in Sudbury
and then into Stroh market there was a
working group that was set up to
lessons from previous areas where it had
been introduced and I think that
creative and proactive way of working
was one of the reasons we are where we
are today and that the team are managing
in it really well and this income
management policy as well on the
emphases on intervention is also very
useful in dealing with these issues so I
think the team have really got it under
control as much as is possible to be
under control I think it's worth
remembering as well as if anybody
contacts you in your ward before when it
was that when it was local somebody
could phone up at one of our offices and
they would talk to the benefits team and
they would be able to sort it out there
and then but because it's now done by
another department it's much more
difficult to deal with that so that
caused extra stress and extra workload
for the team as well so the fact that
you're suggesting recommending that a
report does only comes back when an
issue is raised is very useful because
obviously there's work involved in
coming to scrutiny and offices time so I
think the scrutiny committee for that
recommendation
yes thank you very much for your
attendance that is the end of the
meeting the meeting is closed but I
think just because I brought in a rich
fruitcake as it's my birthday today so
if anyone wants a bit of cake didn't
have it with coffee